welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and dr. streams introduced the MCA
de magic sass and ways to defeat
villains without a Hulk smashed the
madness of Stevie strange has been a
mystery I've explored those a fourteen
million six hundred and five times ever
since the old days of my 2016 breakdown
but YouTube took that down much music so
I'm back and I've come to bargain
because I found a ton of new miserable
details to open our eye to the source of
Supremes future in the multiverse of
madness film opens in comer Tosh
kuselias steals the page of the book of
Cagliostro and these sacred books have
glowing cover pieces almost as if
they're alive when kycilia slits it thud
to the floor it's almost like two souls
in this library lost chunks the ancient
one blocks their escape hypocrite his
charge is because she uses energy from
the Dark Dimension to manipulate reality
something she masks with her hood here
later we see the Dark Dimension forehead
symbol that she was hiding composer
Michael Giacchino's music builds to a
cacophony of horns
[Music]
really like the essence of am I looking
at he's evoking dawn Davis's score from
the matrix that films an inspiration
brow this movie later compares the rules
of reality to programs in source code
kycilia soap it's a portal and he looked
closely one of his zealots falls right
past missing it into this guy for it
our first shots of our heroes Stephen
strange shows his hands giving those of
us in May 2020 and EPS a in this film
strangest hands are a synecdoche of
parts of him that represents his whole
self and his character evolution in act
one he's so goddamn proud of these
ticklers reflecting his ego until the
hands are shattered along with this
pride in act two his multiverse
confusion is reflected with infinite
hands and an act three a hand close-up
reflects him finally connecting with his
mentor's wisdom followed by a return to
the hand washed and close-up to wash her
blood off his hands and his hands come
in the face of the woman he mistreated
strange shows off his mastery of album
released years and he makes west cover
his watch as he operates this film is
obsessed with time of course to
foreshadow the big reveal the time stone
but also to establish this film's deeper
meaning as a story about conquering
death itself strangest goal in this
moment isn't really to save a life it's
to save you to inevitable mortality but
a ticking clock reminds him that he is
finite a lesson that serves him well as
he joins the infinity saga hey if you
were given a chance to be the hero of
your own fantasy you take that chance
right of course you would that's why you
should play raid
shadow legends it's where dark fantasy
meets realism and then those two things
have a baby and the baby is a game where
you can be a door fight and a lizard man
raid is free to download and play and
available on both mobile and PC I like
to play the dungeon battles where you
get a squad of your champions and you
get to take on a boss and his goons for
a reward yeah yeah you can upgrade your
champions and outfit them with cool
weapons and armor you can join a clan
and like the clan boss and you can jump
into the arena and fight against other
raid players challenge yourself in the
ongoing tournaments fighting this
spider's Den the almighty fired Knights
boy than a
it's dragon and now in raid patch 1.15
is coming in May and with it you'll be
able to compete in a brand new arena
tournament earn points according to your
tier and went awesome rewards in the
local and global tournament
speaking of rewards the more you play
the more rewards you get so what are you
waiting for go to the video description
click on the special links and if you
are a new player you will get 100,000
silver plus one free champion gram water
I thought about it what this tell Gimli
looking do it on your side all this
treasure will be waiting for you here
those rewards are available to new
players only for the next 30 days good
luck and I'll see you there
strangest fancy home like it's them to
Tony Stark who's former residents of
Avengers tower we can see in the skyline
here we linger on strangest collection
of watches similar to the one Tony Stark
had and Iron Man 2 but where's that
movie show Tony's selling off the watch
given to him by Obadiah Stane strange
keeps his watches like prize 2 heirlooms
a poor attempt to master time throughout
all this he keeps his watch from
Christine similarly to Steve Rogers
Peggy compass it's his guiding force
that breaks to reflect his break from
his ticking clock obsession his award is
dated 2016 as it's his watch specific
day February 2nd at 2016 making this yes
Groundhog Day which I pointed out four
years ago foreshadows the Groundhog Day
style time loops of this movie's climax
to get a good sense of the timeline in
this movie the tree in the Kamaraj
courtyard tells the passage of time from
spring to autumn to winter suggesting
that strange spent the time in 2016 2017
during Civil War secluded in Wizard
training strength listens to
interstellar overdrive' by Pink Floyd a
band who actually used Doctor Strange
artwork in their album art for a
Saucerful of Secrets later strange wears
a shirt from Pink Floyd's Syd Barrett's
solo album the madcap laughs' his
assistant passes along some cases I've
got a 35 year old airforce Colonel
crushed his lower spine and sometimes
terminal Armour mid thoracic burst
fracture many thought this could have
been referring to Air Force Colonel
James Rhodes who boomed out his back
during civil war director scott
derrickson said no but it could also
refer to the hammer test pilot in Iron
Man 2 but I guess that would mean that
patient went like several years without
surgery the next patient I have a 68
year old female with an advanced
brainstem glioma yeah want me to screw
up my perfect record streams dick Ashley
says an elderly woman isn't worth
operating on yet later in this film he
does everything he can to save an
ancient woman even when her death does
technically ruin his record and the
final patients how about a 22 year old
female with an electronic implant in her
brain to control schizophrenia struck by
lightning that does sound interesting
[Applause]
at one point we wondered if this could
have been Carol Danvers who'd in
schizophrenia type false memories
implanted in her brain by decree of
course her origin was in 1989 but there
was this long gap in her timeline from
1995 through 2018 they will see some
future side story wearing 2016 she and
storm got in a fight here ex due to
distracted driving the end credits
actually have a PSA about distracted
driving which is a fun nod to strangers
later joke about warnings coming too
late too you know you really should have
stone the whole book because the
warnings the warnings come after the
spouse stranger struggles to write his
name and image lifted directly from a J
michael Straczynski
comics panel and he finds miracle
patient Jonathan Payne born the plays a
bball gotta be an in-joke to Benjamin
brats a previous superhero movie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa in Nepal
more dough takes strange to meet the
ancient one who was expecting him isn't
that why you're here you've undergone
many procedures seven right mm-hmm an
endgame she confirms that she had been
waiting for him since at least 2012
you're about five years too early
Stephen strange is currently performing
surgery about 20 blocks that way
but stranger skeptical no such thing as
spirit we are made of matter nothing
more
you're just another tiny momentary speck
within an indifferent universe these
words will be repeated exactly by
strangest future enemy what about the
people you killed the moment I respect
within an additional universe strangers
biggest enemy it's his own ego ancient
one knocks him to the astral plane a
move repeated with Hulk and endgame she
said some spiraling through the
multiverse we got a breakdown this
accent trip frame by frame with a trip
down it begins with the ancient one
saying he's referring to the third eye
concept the eye that opens the spirit to
divine consciousness but it's also a
clue for how strange will conquer death
by opening his eye of agamotto like Tony
Stark strange breaks from Earth's
atmosphere freaked out and then he taps
this butterfly which if you think about
it it's the final evolved stage of the
requried cocoon imagery throughout
marble face - we don't need to be
protected they need to evolve everything
in the MCU has evolved towards the
multiverse being real and now that
cocoon is hatching derrickson confirmed
influences like Stanley Kubrick's
dimension travel a 2001 a Space Odyssey
and the wormhole travel in contact which
you can see in the wormhole design in
the background and the way strangest
face bends and then pulls from reality
just like Jodie Foster's did at one
point strange disintegrates into dust
and then reforms much like he'll do an
infinity war and when he returns an
in-game and a note that the sexy hand
he'll is initially a cavern with
strangest face all over the walls his
hands represent itself and right now his
self is infinite and confused strange
briefly floats through the quantum realm
that ant-man recently visited the
Ancient Ones vo calls this example of a
dimension that's some benevolent and
life-giving in ant-man and the wasp they
get quantum healing energy from here
and there's some subatomic life with a
hidden civilization and of course the
Avengers use the time vortexes in this
realm to restore the lives Santos took
we also got our first look at the Dark
Dimension and drama mu which was based
on Steve Ditko's comic artwork in a
black light painting the derrickson had
in his office the camera Taj Wi-Fi
password is Shambala a nod to into
Shambhala a Doctor Strange graphic novel
that deals with the death of the ancient
one as he will in this film new
librarian is Wong who in the comics is
actually the son of Amir the Hermit
master come here in this movie
Trainz compares is one name name to
beyond saved Wong listens to later
Wong's surrender to the material world
is just one of my favorite recurring
bits I want to say no to a tomb and
again the rare books hang in these
chains our friend Lin a sear on discord
put it out during our watch along in
this movie how books are chained up like
this in medieval scriptorium Xin an
Oxford's current library you should join
our discord by the way it's fun and
beneath the book of Cagliostro there's
an another empty spot for some book
that's been removed many believe this
could have been the dark hold the Marvel
spell book that showed up in agents of
shield strange man escapes down to a
goatee is look in the comics there's
actually based on Vincent Price that's
why Stephen strange is middle name is
Vincent Mordo teacher strange about
relics this is the staff of the Living
Tribunal the real Living Tribunal is a
giant deity who judges the multiverse
there's actually gonna be a scene
infinity war in which dr. Strange's
wizard duel with Thanos would have
featured a Living Tribunal cameo and
trial that would have judged Thanos says
beauty but this staff just seems to be
named after the figure because again
he's a giant he also shows off the bull
team boots of bull tour based on the
vapors of altar or maybe the Vipers of
volt or in the comics strange uses these
again infinity war with Peter quill
strange uses the eye of agamotto to
manipulate time with this Apple it
progresses like a flipbook with each
bite taken out of it accompanied by a
munch sound effect a munch that they
reverse munch when it goes in Reverse
filmmakers chose the Apple symbol to
symbolize the forbidden fruit essence of
strange stealing this ancient godly
wisdom this also shows us how time loops
were localized to whatever you're
focusing on so when Thanos rewinds the
clock on Wanda destroying the mind stone
doesn't rewind all of time and all of
his past actions before that he just
reminds a red juicy flesh he wants to
take a bite out of more dough and Wong
berate him temporal manipulation can
create bran
is unstable dimensional openings special
paradoxes time loops you want to get
stuck reliving the same moment over and
over forever or never having existed at
all these are the same rules a time
travel that forced the Avengers to
return the Infinity stones back to their
places of origin in the timeline and
in-game the relics in the New York
sanctum include a helmet that looks like
Black Knights like nineties a legacy
hero of Dean Whitman in the upcoming
eternals film kycilia skills Daniel drum
who in the comics is brother - Jericho
drama cave brother voodoo strange tries
to use the breezier of bomb galiyev
which of the comics is used for
transportation and concealment when
they're hiding from it disto actually
shows up in the collectors vault on
guardians mission breakout ride at
Disneyland strange binds Casillas in
this kinky device confirmed to be the
crimson bands of cyttorak which in the
comics is a red lasso spell case alias
Rance de strange and stirs his desire to
conquer death for well beyond son
because time is one of slaves his time
he's an insult strains first cy Wong
previously slayed about to Ramu
and he hungers for us most of all the
fact that our dimension has time and
that things die is what makes us unique
and desirable two of those other
dimensions like I say Lee's grins which
one is that uselessly
this sneaky jewel snatching gotcha is a
similar trick that strange hints to Tony
in endgame when Tony slips the weapon
off Thanos his fingers to get the last
laugh strange also mirrors start by
having his lady fix his heart the image
of estriol strange watching over his
physical body get operated on was lifted
from the o'the comics strangely sky
silliest in a trippy foot chase this
starts with him reaching an impossible
intersection then the camera swoops
around to reveal that cross street is on
a higher plane and then back into the
close-up it's actually similar to the
impossible staircase shot in Inception
case Ilyas comes to behind him shoving
mirror wall shards out of his way and
then he rotates the city so that strange
and weird Oh smack into a bus with
Stanley he raids Aldous Huxley's the
doors of perception and essay on a
psychedelic drug trip when many writings
that inspired the Doctor Strange comics
they run up the side of a building that
bins and waves kind of like the building
Trinity's helicopter crashes into in the
matrix
Avengers tower once again shows up in a
little detail here on the folded Street
a cab
cuts off another car by turning into the
wrong lane I guess drivers are a-holes
in every dimension the ancient one
assembles this game board made up of
city surfaces including the train
platforms of Wall Street Church Street
Columbus Circle in the Museum of Natural
History Buckeye cilia stabs through his
own zealot to killer and she pulls the
ancient one beautifully slows her final
moments I spent so many years peering
through time looking at this exact
moment but I can't see past it I've
prevented countless terrible futures and
after each one there's always another
and they all lead here but never further
I never saw your future only its
possibilities strange could see past his
dusting because there remained at least
one future possibility in which the
Avengers brought him back and Stark made
sure he'd stayed back but that's not the
case for her so she can't see past her
death she leaves them with this critical
lesson he's not about you I saw the
cameras swings around the ancient one to
show how strange is finally seeing
through her mind and shifting his
perspective about his own ego
the final battle Wong gears up with the
other sorcerers he bears the one that
would tomb an artifact from the comics
he's also a shot here of Tina manaro
mother of Nico Minoru who in the comics
kycilia Rives with some zealots notice
their portal came from the Saharan
desert earlier strange trapped one of
these zealots in that desert location
meaning case Elias leaves no zealot
behind except ones that fall up forever
Mordo feels betrayed well she drew on
its power to steal centuries of life she
did what she thought was right the bill
comes to you he's quoting the 2016
comics in which strange received
warnings like this for Wiggly magic
attracting anti magic scientists the
empirical hoody powered sorcerers of
Earth which is what Mordo claims as his
new mo in the post-credits scene saucers
strange uses the time stone to rewind
the destruction of Hong Kong and to
match this reverse motion Shiki no score
plays in Reverse as well the reversing
chaos create some awesome obstacles
strange and Kai silliest get pushed back
by reassembling barrels as elet fighting
morto it's distracted by a flaming gas
line so she doesn't see the returning
manhole cover that had exploded off it
and that dummy gets flushed
back in with the waters of a ruptured
lobster tank youch
Mordo watches as a boot of a crash
victim gushes back into the guy's head
as he flies back into the car he just
crashed out of this helps Mordo get a
bearing of what's going on so that he
can use this environment trapping ones
eyelet on the other side of glass and
kai sillies behind a wall so unlike past
movies where the goal is to close a
portal to keep the chaos out derrickson
wanted to explore what would happen if
the hero flies through the portal to
stop the chaos in a different way
I've come to bargain after hearing Kai
sillies repeat how Dormammu is attached
from time Eve remembers the Ancient Ones
final words we don't get to choose our
time death is what gives life meaning to
know your days are numbered your time is
short yes death in time are not our
worlds weaknesses they are what make our
world powerful so strange weaponize this
time using a groundhog day style time
loop to drive Dormammu insane notice on
the second loop we don't cut from
strange and a new strange just hops up
in the same frame because this is how it
looks from dormammu's point of view it's
confusing there's no cut it's just one
endless hell moment with an immortal
whack Amole in total strange dies 12
times on screen but like in Groundhog
Day it is implied that it could have
been thousands he was an old friend
by the way Dormammu is voiced by
Benedict Cumberbatch again strangest
battle in this movie is between him and
his Mon ego also they didn't want to pay
another actor when they had Smaug
already on payroll yeah and he ends up
not defeating Dormammu but bargaining
with him to stay the hell away because
as the ancient one said we never lose
our demons moody we only learn to live
above them Wong confirms eye of agamotto
holds the time stone in a post-credits
scene in duck strange into the Infinity
saga in a clip from thor ragnarok
strange now wears his yellow gloves from
the comics and I love the practical
sleight of hand with the T turning to
the full pint glass in the same shot
being a stagehand to be right at a frame
to do that switch but the film's final
moments show strange with christine's
watch his face is still broken his hand
still scarred and trembling he never
fully healed his flesh but he conquered
death by deciding that pain is an old
friend that he could live with
Cumberbatch maintains this tremble every
time he returns a strange
down
and he signaled stark in endgame and
that Avengers partnership is hidden in
the final shot looking down on the
Sancta sanctorum on Bleecker Street with
New York's financial district in the
background that makes this shot coming
from the Northeast exactly the angle of
Avengers tower in Midtown as if we are
standing on its observation deck looking
down to Bleecker Street wondering what
is that strange window now The Avengers
have moved upstate by now but the beacon
that ended the first Avengers now shines
down on the newest protector of this
reality quick reminder that to offset
our small businesses financial struggles
we have Bernard with a wonderful hand
sanitiser just a nice thing you can do
to help us companies stay alive follow
me on Instagram and Twitter I da boss
follow new rockstars it subscribe to see
me dig through that big old corpse pile
and Guardians vol 2 and a pretty sure
James Gunn is just using to drive me
insane
[Music]